[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده من
حلقات افكار الاستاذ استاذنا الدكتور جوده
عبد الخالق وفي هذه الحلقه ايضا بنست انف
طرح اسئله حضراتكم على الدكتور مساء الخير
مع الدكتور مساء الحريه
ربنا يخلي حضرتك كان في سؤال طرح وحضرتك
اصلا طرحته هنا وهذا السؤال بيسال اصحابه
عن ما هو النظام الاقتصادي القائم الان
والذي تراه الافضل هناك عده نظم اقتصاديه
موجوده في العالم فما هو النظام الافضل
اللي تعتقد انه اذا تبنينا يبقى ده يعني
ليس في الامكان كان ابدع مما كان كبدايه
عايز بس اقول لما نتكلم على النظام
الاقتصادي النظام الاقتصادي ا هو النظام
او بمعنى اصح مجموعه القواعد والترتيبات
التي تقدم اجابه على ثلاث اسئله سؤال
الاول من الذي يملك وسائل
الانتاج مضبوط السؤال
الثاني كيف تتم عمليه الانتاج وعلى اساس
السؤال الثالث كيف تتم عمليه التوزيع
الانتاج عندك دي الاسئله الثلاثه اللي
جوهر اي نظام اقتصادي من الذي يملك وسائل
الانتاج ليكن مثلا الدوله ام القطاع الخاص
مظبوط يعني دول الفرقين
الطرفين النقطه الثانيه كيف تتم عمليه
الانتاج بمعنى الج بمعنى انه قرارات
الانتاج ما هي الاليه التي تتم طبقا لها
يعني هل طبقا لاليه السوق او طبقا لخطه
ا شامله من المركز وا الى القطاعات
المختلفه السؤال الاني واللي بتتم من خلال
المركز هذه الدول الاشتراكيه بكل انواعها
واللي بتتم من خلال السوق هذا هي الول
الراس ماليه الراس ماليه السؤال الثالث هو
السؤال الثالث كيف يتم توزيع الانتاج
هنا عندنا برضو نقيضين نقيض انه التوزيع
يتم طبقا ل مساهمه كل عنصر في العمليه
الانتاجيه الاسلوب الثاني لا انه التوزيع
بيتم طبقا لتصور مركزي حول الاحتياجات
والمتطلبات لكل شريحه من شرائح المجتمع
وهنا بتبقى قضيه التوزيع قضيه مهمه جدا
و تعتبر مكون اساسي من مكونات الخطه التي
تدير الاقتصاد وبناء على ذلك بشكل رئيسي
حاليا المطروح على الساحه هو نظامان
النظام الاول لراس مالي وه المكتسح فيما
يبدو حاليا الى حين النظام الثاني هو نظام
الاشتراكي في
نظام ممكن اعتبره هجين انجاز التعبير
واكبر مثال ليه الصين لو قلنا النموذج
النقي للنظام الراسمالي هو النظام
الامريكي الاقتصاد الامريكي النظام
النقي او النموذج النقي لنظام الاشتراكي
هو
نظام الصين قبل
التحول اللي حصل 78 مظبوط 78 بعد 78 ابتد
النظام يطلع انه نظام بيسموه
[موسيقى]
ا اشتراكيه السوق هو نظام اشتراكي ولكن
بيدار طبقا لاليه السوق في تداخل ولذلك
يصعب ان احنا نلاقي نظام نقي بالمعنى
الكامل وبالتالي بقول في نظام حجيم بين
هذا وذاك اللي هو ا نظام السوء الاجتماعي
وده النظام اللي سايد في بلد زي المانيا
ددول الاكناب دي الثلاث دي دي البدائل
الثلاثه المطروحه عظيم حضرتك اللي بتشوفه
النموذج الافضل نسبيا ايه اه شوف ال نظام
انا في رايني النموذج الافضل هو
النموذج السوق الاجتماعي لانه خلي بالك
النظام
الراسمالي بيتضمن تكلفه عاليه جدا
ا سواء بالنسبه الفرد او المجتمع وانا
بتكلم من زاويه ان انا متابع مثلا للحاله
الامريكيه
وعارف اعداد الضحايا لهذا لهذا النظام
ا وايضا البشريه كله مثلا كثير لا يعرفوا
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بيمثلوا
حوالي 5 او 6% من سكان العالم ويلوث بمعدل
لا يقل عن
ربع الملوثات ا غازات الاحتباس الحراري و
في حكمها اللي في العالم بالضبط بالاضافه
الى الاستنزاف الرهيب لموارد كوكب الارض
وفي النهايه موارد محدوده وبالتالي انا في
تقديري ربما اقتصاد السوء الاجتماعي هو
النظام الافضل في المطلق ولكن لما نيجي
نفص على مقاس بلد دي نقطه مهمه جدا القضيه
نس قدريه انك بتروح عند محل وتشتري بدله
لانه اذا في تفاوتات في الاحجام يبقى هنا
لابد
توفق على المقاس في بطيات ثقافيه لابد ان
تاخذ في الاعتبار في موضعات اجتماعيه في
امور تتعلق بالموقع يعني موقع البلد من
خريطه العالم
وبالتالي طبيعه تفاعلاته مع البيئه
المحيطه له دي امور بتحكم في
النهايه النظام المناسب النظام المناسب في
تحديدات النهائيه اذا حضرتك بتقول ان
نسبيا ما بين الانظمه اللي موجوده النظام
اللي تراه انه هو كان اكثر فاعليه في خدمه
الشعوب اللي بيطبق فيها هو نظام السوق
الاجتماعي وهي مطبقه منذ سنوات في الدول
الاسكندنافيه وفي المانيا والى حد كبير في
الصين
واذكر الاصدقاء وارجو ان حضك تصححي يعني
ان هذا النظام حضك مره وصفته بانه اذا
كان السوق فوق الانسان في الاسواق
الراسماليه زي الولايات متحده في هذه في
هذا النظام السوق في خدمه الانسان فوق
السوق الان مظبوط واظن من حيث التفصيل انه
في هذه الدول بيحصلوا ضريبه عاليه نسبيا
ويعد توزيعها للفئات الاكثر احتياجا طيح
لانه برض بهذه المناسبه سيد ا وضح نقطه
مهمه انه ا مجمل ما يخرج من عمليه الانتاج
ا نوعين من السلع سلع خاصه وسلع عامه سلعه
الخاص هي سلع يمكن الحصول عليها وتداولها
من خلال السوق وانتاجها ايضا من خلال
السوق اما السلع العامه اللي هي من قبيل
التعليم والصحه والامن والدفاع والعداله
فهذه مجالات لا يمكن بكفاءه ان تنتج من
خلال السوق وبالتالي لابد ان تنظم من خلال
الدوله بشكل او او باخر ولذلك هناك ضروره
في خصوصا في بلد لو اتكلمنا على مصر او
العربيه بشكل عام بينها مشتركات لو بلد
عايز ينمو ف من اهم شروط النمو والنهضه جز
التعبير انه الاستثمار في البشر دي نقطه
مهمه جدا استثمار البشر يتطلب تنظيم عمليه
انتاج وتداول واتاح السلعه العامه من خلال
المال العام اه ده فكره دي كت انا اصلا
كنت عاوز احرك على السلعه العامه اللي انا
اتتها قبل كده فحضرتك بتقول ان في السلعه
الخاصه دي زي الملابس والسيارات وب الى
الى اخره انما السلعه العامه بقى اللي
بتشمل الصحه والتعليم والامن والعداله الى
اخره ده لازم الدوله تستثمر فيها لان دي
سلع لازم الدوله تكون يعني بتدها بكفاءه
وبرشا يعني صحيح لسبب فني طبعا انا مش
عايز ارق المشاهدين بالكلام ده انما السلع
العامه ا اهم مميزه في الواقع اهم ما
يميزها انك انت
ا ممكن جدا اللي
يملكها لا يستاثر بالمردود بتاعها وحده
وانما جزء من المردود يعود على المجتمع
ولا يمكن استيداء المقابل بالاعتماد على
السوق يعني تاخد مثال لو اتكلمنا على
التعليم الشخص اللي
تعليمه متقدم
وعالي هذا في حد ذات يعود بنفع ليس عليه
فقط وانما على الاخرين في المجمل طبعا نفس
الشيء لو بتتكلم على خدنا الحاله العكسيه
بقى اللي هي السلع العامه السلبيه زي
التلوث على سبيل المثال التلوث لو عندك
مصنع بينتج اسمنت بيطلق في الهواء كميه
عاليه جدا من الغبار هذا الغبار بيصيب
المنطقه المحيطه به ولا يمكن الزام الشركه
المنتجه للاسمنت انها تعوض هؤلاء
الناس عن الاضرار الناتجه عن عمليه اللي
الانتاج دي بنسميها الخارجيات
السلبيه كما في هذه الحاله الخريات
الايجابيه لو عندك واحد عنده بيت والبيت
له حديقه والحديقه فيها مناظر جميله
ورائحه طيبه بيستفيد منه كل خلق الله ولا
يمكن انك انت تاخد تمن ايه ممن هذه
الانشطه الخارجيه دي بالانجليز تبقى ايه
اكسترنال الاثار التي تنتج من عمل المنشاه
ولكنها تتجاوز نطاق المنشاه ولا يمكن
تنظيمها من خلال السوق طب انا لي سؤالين
وننتقل الى سؤال اخر السؤال الاول هل ممكن
بما ان احنا طرحنا السلع العامه تديني
امثله لان انا كان في ذهني بس اللي هو
الجزء الاولاني الصحه التعليم الامن
الدفاع العدل هل هي اوسع من
كده هي اساسا هذه ولكن في
سياقات معينه قد تجد امثله مختلفه انما
لذلك انا بركز على جوهر السلع العامه جوهر
السلع العامه انه لا يمكن
تنظيم استهلاكها من خلال السوق فقط ولا
يمكن تنظيمها من انتاجها من خلال السوق
فقط ولكن لابد من ان يتم هذا في اطار قدر
ما من تدخل الدوله او المجتمع في
عمليه الانتاج طب والسلع العامه السلبيه
اللي اشرت اليها ده في حاجه اسمه سلع عامه
السلبيه اه طبعا اللي هي او نسميها احنا
الخارجيات الخارجيات مثلا زي التلوث
التلوث اكبر مثال واحنا بنتكلم عن التغير
المناخي التلوث هو اكبر مثال على السلع
العامه
السلبيه وبالتالي هنا لما تيجي
تشوف في اطار الجدل الدائر حول كيفيه
التعامل مع التغيرات المناخيه في عمليات
تبادل الكربون اسواء الكربون كل القصه دي
هي محاولات يعني ناجعه في حدود معينه في
محاوله التعامل مع معضله الخريجات السلبيه
الممثله في في التلوث السؤال الاخير هو في
شكل ملحوظه اذا حضرتك لما بتقول انك بتفضل
نظام السوق
الاجتماعي بتفضله لانه الدوله بتلعب فيه
دور اكبر في اداره السلع العامه اللي
السوق صعب صعب انه تترك للسوق مظبوط صعب
ان انا اقول ل مثلا التعليق الصحه تك من
يستطيع ان يدفع اما من لا يدفع فخلاص بقى
يص يعني يترك راضه مش ده اللي ح تقصده
صحيح صحيح ده جميل جدا دي اجابه اظن ان هي
واضحه جدا وان كانت الحقيقه الموضوع مغري
بال بالمزيد بمزيد من الاسئله جزيل الشكر
معال الدكتور اهلا بيك